filming a show like hostile planet comes
with a lot of unique challenges check
out this from behind the scenes okay
ready one of the aims of hostile planet
was to try and immerse the viewer in the
world of the animals you want to film
something people haven't seen before or
film it in a new surprising way which is
going to be difficult we went to the
heart of Ecuadorian Andes to film
hummingbirds that's nice we spent four
weeks out there filming 12 hours a day
every day just to capture this
hummingbird sequence that's the one I
think it looks great but it's really
challenging to capture how arming bird
moves because you can barely see it so
this is a phantom high-speed camera it's
one of the cameras that can record
almost as fast as the Omnibus comprised
of what we've done is we've suspended
this rather expensive camera from a rope
and we've created a little hummingbird
paradise here and the idea is that we
can just move the camera and so we get
that feeling of flying with the
hummingbirds
that's very nice he's super sharp that
may sound easy the shots over in half a
second this camera allows us to take
that half a second and stretch out into
30
[Music]
we've also wanted to give the
perspective of what it's like to be a
hummingbird flying through the forest so
we got this racing drone pilot to go out
with us and fly his really fast for
agile drone dodging between the trees he
came for five days and the first two
days it rained solidly and you're just
thinking how can we get the sequence but
we got inventive you'll see the very
expert taping around the whole drone
just to keep the water out because it
just keeps on pouring and then we had to
build a little roof for it
isn't she a beauty water dripping
everywhere so you think you got the most
perfect shot and there's you know this
splash of water on your lens is like
after a while we actually realized that
that looked really good maybe you feel
immersed in this environment in a way
the clean image would
we enter the project with the idea that
we were going to try and push things as
much as possible I know what we're
trying to do I'm seeing the raw footage
and I'm going that's incredible that's
when you know it's gonna work I hope
you'll be blown away because I know I
was
[Music]